the Super Bowl of style is ramping up in
New York welcome to Entertainment
Tonight all right let's go right to
Rachel Smith who's at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York City home of
the Met Gala hey Rachel what's going on
okay I have so much excitement and of
course the finishing touches are being
put on the Met staircase which is in
that tent right behind me the weather is
cool but clear the fans are lining the
streets the style stars are ready to
fully Embrace their Empire State of Mind
at the Met Gala
[Music]
[Applause]
wow yes wow Riri invented show-stopping
Chanel nailed to the medgal assignment a
day early and showed up for baby bump
s
the paparazzi were loving Rihanna's faux
fur look by the late designer Carl
lagerfelt who's being honored tonight
this will be the third Met Gala for Nick
Jonas and Priyanka Chopra who enjoyed a
date night out in New York also out can
you confirm your dating when Powell
euphoria's Sydney Sweeney that's her
leaving her hotel Saturday being asked
about Affair rumors with her anyone but
you co-star the night before the actress
and her fiance Jonathan devino stepped
out but there was not PDA and no
engagement ring also tonight all eyes
will be on Gisele Bundchen who's
expected to attend solo it's her first
big appearance since her divorce from
Tom Brady other First Met Gala virgins
Paris Hilton and Florence Pugh in
Valentino will make their debut it's so
hot there's so many pretty things Kim
Kardashian got some pre-med pampering at
the reality star posted this video
thanking North for surprising her with a
massage and this could be the night
Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny make their
rumored relationship red carpet official
they grab dinner Saturday night at New
York Hot Spot Carbone
lizza will be back she was all smiles in
a vision and violets as she arrived to
Anna Winters pre-met Gala dinner last
night last year she gave this unfiltered
review you get there you gotta get out
and there's a long line I'm taking the
glamor away from it but it's true I was
sweating they don't got no chairs no
cocktails as stars like Christina Ricci
getting a facial and Doja cat dropped
hints about their preps I got a first
look at what the celebs will see inside
Crow Lagerfeld a line of Beauty costume
exhibit I think I looked at about 10 000
images and about 2000 pieces narrowed it
down to 200.
[Music]